Let's get to unemployment.
We have a situation right now where to stop
the virus from spreading to stop the invisible
scourge or scored.
Just Trump calls it from spreading noticed.
By the way, Trump has not mentioned the Chinese
virus in his last three press conferences.
Clearly somebody got to him.
But now the invisible enemy, the invisible
scourge is what he says.
We need people to stay home.
That's the point.
For some people.
This merely means you work from home and not
much changes for others.
For many people, this means their employer
is closing down.
They no longer have a job, or at least they
don't have one until things open back up,
which Donald Trump wants to apparently start
doing around Easter time.
He wants the churches packed for Easter.
We now have a report about the number of new
unemployment claims this past week, and the
number is three million, three million, two
hundred and eighty three thousand.
This is a staggering number when you look
at new claims per week going all the way back
to the mid 1960s.
It is a stunning number.
Now, to give you some context, the expected
new claims for last week, we get the numbers
the week after.
So that's why we're looking at last week.
This week could be even worse.
Expected new claims last week were 1.6 million.
That's what we were expecting.
Economists actual claims came in at just under
3.3 million.
Actual claims doubling the expected new claims.
And for reference, the previous record for
new claims in a week was in 1982 when there
were six hundred and ninety five thousand
new claims.
Now, of course, you've got to adjust for population
growth in the United States, but still a crooked
number to take a baseball phrase.
Of course, all these numbers from the U.S.
Department of Labor.
So this was last week.
Now, since the reporting is on a delay, this
week's numbers will come in next week.
This week's numbers could be even worse because
we've seen more states start to shut down
and we could see potentially even worse numbers
next week.
Now, if you're looking for anything, anything,
anything at all to mitigate the obvious absolute
and total disaster of these numbers, there
is one thing that I will say, and this does
not this is just a reality.
A lot of these jobs aren't truly jobs that
are over.
These are furloughs.
These are sort of like leaves of absence.
And when these businesses can get going again
and not all of them.
Well, a lot of these jobs are very quickly
going to come off of the unemployment numbers.
How soon that could be?
We don't know.
And of course, the longer this goes, some
businesses aren't going to be able to make
it through.
Restaurants are a tragic example.
Imagine a restaurant in a city with a $5000
a month rent payment, which is not not unusual
for restaurants in a city.
Imagine they have, you know, 15 employees
on a regular base basis, including a lot of
waitstaff.
Right now, for example, in Massachusetts,
they're doing takeout only.
There may be down from 15 employees to three
employees, just people cooking, and the owner
is handling orders because their state has
a stay at home order.
Their revenue is drastically reduced after
they pay their three employees and they pay
their rent and utilities.
They may still be losing money if they don't
get rent support.
If there aren't rent deferrals at a certain
point, maybe they can do it for a month.
Maybe they can do it for two months because
they want to keep their business.
They'll go out of their pocket to keep it
running on a takeout only basis.
But eventually you're going to see these business
owners start to just walk away.
And that's why we've got to grin and bear
it now together at the same time.
If 20 states do stuff now and then 5 stop
and 6 more start next with it, it's not going
to work.
Okay.
If half the country does nothing, we're just
going to extend this and it's going to be
longer and longer.
It might be less bad in individual spots for
a little while until it's not.
We're starting to see Louisiana become a hotspot.
We're starting to see places now ramp up the
cases.
The real path is and what Trump should say,
if if Trump again, if Trump is determined
to say he wants to reopen on Easter, which
is crazy, Trump should say, I want to reopen
on Easter, but I need all 50 governors.
I need every state to stay home, shut down
all nonessential businesses, take out and
delivery only at restaurants, cancel unnecessary
medical appointments, no schooling, etc, etc.
Trump should say I need that for the next
17 days.
If you want me to be able to reopen partially,
you know, maybe young people in some states.
I don't know if he's determined to do it.
Say you need all 50 states to do the damn
thing because otherwise it's not going to
happen.
Otherwise this is going to extend and the
numbers are going to go up and up and up.
That's what's happening.
And we're gonna go go look at those numbers
a little bit later.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram for continued coverage and
funny pictures to add a little levity at David
Pakman show on Instagram while you're there.
Follow me.
David got packed